you to death exclusive champions se
trouve sur aws inferno un jeu d'horreur
qui a l'air extrêmement spéciale on peut
le voir rien qu'au menu ok c'est parti
en faisant traîner dans le métro et rer
parisiens ta phoques ou la date
officielle jeu blanc déjà votre fils
s'envole déjà aura ramed son fils wazza
salut y est ok oprah quelle direction
celle-ci ou l'autre moi je pense que ça
va être l'autre d'accord bombe alors moi
je prends plus le métro parisien
c'est fini ok bah ouais t'as je sais pas
si j'ouvre totalement alors je peux pas
l'infirmer
ok ce qu'est ce que c'est que ça qu'est
ce qui nous vaut lui j'ai bien peur la
wii un morceau de verre pour le morceau
de gauche clic gauche pour leur [ __ ]
ok alors si vous êtes épileptique les
gens je vous souhaite une très bonne
mort ok ok ok moi je juge eux c'est pas
moi c'est pas vrai non moi je suis juste
là comme ça weight gollum et avec tout
ce soir oh la vache
c'est parti poss dos comme quoi la
violence pour la violence
excuse moi je suis désolé excuse moi
reste à une certaine distance demeure
tout de même
ok donc tu le couple à têtu tu portes la
direction je suis ton guide à travers
cet enfer je veux pas de toi top arrête
il fait du breakdance acquis la peau
pourquoi c'est un spectacle qu'est ce
qui se passe dans l'ue il va nous aider
lui il va nous aider
tu peux venir m'aider enfin la vraie
ferme ta gueule
d'accord vas-y [ __ ] mille pattes mais
laisse moi tranquille aussi
tiens tiens voilà je te mettais des
jetons mais des doigts dans le dos moi
moi je suis comme ça je vais dévoilant
le dos aux gens qui attirent j'ai juste
compris monde sur mon dos comment je
monte sur ton dos [ __ ] monde sur le
dos de gaulle où moi je dis ça je dis
rien on fait du rose ou sur coup double
ok c'est bon on y est on y va on fait
tourner au boulou il a une oreille un
peu plein de cérumen quand même moi je
dis ça je dis rien c'est hardcore
merci gollum 1 allée eye-fi dff couteau
désagréable fès extrêmement c'est que
c'est ok ça lui met sa tête a tout gâché
sa tête ça tout gâcher je peux pas ok là
sa part quand même sur l'agglo qui tue
d'extrême qu'est-ce qui se passe what we
et c'est là pour la tape dans le dos aux
hommes
ok bon jeu balla gaye 2 ouf le minotaure
il prend trop de transition que cette
phase i est à saluer oh oh oh la la
dièye wizzgo les aléas choix de coeur
vous dit wade wade rhodia olaya d'escaut
motion et slash et slash et tu tape tape
étape ce qui déplaît à on sent qu'il est
un peu fébrile la haye clignote 1 je
pense que c'est un signe de faiblesse
d'un jeu ok disparaît comme ça sans
façon où est mon enfant témoin mon
enfant wata phoque
on est carrément dans un goal of shame
on a vécu des contraintes rôle à tous
les deux tu te souviens sur rodeo
surtout dans le métro il fait carrément
flipper un rigolo mais tu m'avais pas
dit qu'elle est plein de frères
finalement peu importe où peu importe
quand je te suis à ils sont au cinéma ok
les potes même après mieux pour que si
des caisses comment ça se fait elle se
retourne tous saluent attention on va
mettre un coucou des cagoules se
retourne
tu m'as trahi
ok donc bon ça va en voit on voit pas
trop mal extrêmement plaisant ouvre la
porte
qu'est ce que tu veux mais tu veux que
j'aille chez médecins colo colo ok
qu'est ce qui se passe là ça fait une
drôle comme ça sans problème mon fils
vaut absolument rien tout comme vous
ok on a des flashs épileptique de la
mort qui tue trop lol lol xd dernière et
maintenant ils ce qu'on doit faire et je
trouvais un téléphone
[ __ ] mais autant vous dire que j'ai
cherché pendant je sais pas combien de
temps alors ces types art apparemment on
touche les fesses et un escargot géant
cpm coquilles d'escargot ça je suis pas
en train d'halluciner peut-être
peut-être qu'à force de jouer à jeu
finalement devient clairement
psychopathe
ok c'est bon on a fini de toucher les
fesses à l'escargot qui secoue faire
maintenant ma part la pas d'accord tout
simplement
mais c'est vraiment un escargot impute
aux merde on à la merde tchèque antennes
non chez xizhi non plus j'accueille
n'ont pas su par cette porte justice in
that is you you should be dead pattano
sauvegarde open your love and hate you
tu as bien je propose juste qu'on près
de cette porte et qu'on retrouve notre
fiston ou là ou là stop les flèches
d'après flash ok on descend on descend
et est maintenant wattao ouattara qu
attendait puisque je bûche ya moitié
dessus là bas mais j'ai envie de rire
très très fort qu'est-ce qu'ils font ça
fait la fête et on peut même rajouter
petite musique
c'est d'abord au [ __ ] merde c'est un
boss tient son petit coeur tiens tiens
attendez attendez un pur bat un but
comme ça
nous nous devons de mettre des lunettes
ok on y retourne tiens tiens
ah ah on a vu ces faits sur groupe lost
et modifie les eaux pour tap une esquive
mais là il ya un truc là aller mais
comme source ez omg où il a plus de
coeur messieurs c'est ce petit truc la
tipp et 10 rouge là qu'il faut couper
voile elle va tuer il va me rendre
dingue ça ses lunettes et une aide ça me
rend nulle j'en suis sûr
mais regardez c'est et on essaie watts
infos qu'ils apprennent cheap c'est bon
la lt loncin qui pendent est ok d'accord
mais en fait c'est juste le laissez nous
tuer quatre fois de suite voilà mais non
mais non je suis désolé mais c'est
scandaleux office tout je suis si ému de
te retrouver
voilà j'espère que ce jeu probablement
le plus what the fuck auxquels j'ai pu
jusqu'à présent vous aura plu retour
structure d'une nouvelle vidéo voilà
voilà on se voit là je sais pas allez
salut il s'est fait transpercer la tête
par une harpe elena et elena où es tu ça
lui soit il n' a pas du tout du parfait
est-ce que c'est toi